[Music]
in that's so nice news 9 goodbye tiger's
mouth - it's like a [ __ ] 7-eleven
always up there is that common among
kids no I think he might have slight
sinuses as nose probably as always study
I wish she never calls in his mouth me
too really when he causes nothing like
what's wrong
the cute thing is here's it look like a
mouth breather
cuz his tongue is like blocking it yeah
he's not doing like crazy coming down
off your today he was walking and doing
[ __ ] marathons around the kitchen
right he's having a blast I was like
well I wish I could have that much fun
just running in circles man but that was
used just like last week you had but
times have changed it's been a whole
week that's true so a gave out de Torian
who was rejected by his parents is going
to college thanks to donations they just
say gay Valley Torian gave valedictorian
oh I heard right no no III didn't hear I
don't know if I heard correctly cuz I'm
at Gabby's I always hear the wrong [ __ ]
all the time alright so this story is
about Seth Cohen he is 18 years old he
has always wanted to attend college that
was always been his life the goal the
order sounds famous said this is his
teacher / coach teacher that's a young
[ __ ] teacher that looks like it's his
sister
I thought Alyssa's friend that's his
swim coach and so even crazier her in a
[ __ ] bikini that's just always pretty
hot oh I don't remember even the dudes
do dudes were especially hot always yeah
so he
he has always been top of the class he
always he was only four credits shy of
getting a PhD in high school no getting
a degree right when he graduated I saw
his prayers were like oh you gay
get out of here I've been and then
they're like oh that's wrong or worse
brands like I'm not raisin honored
[Music]
nothing to do with day just a cool kid
not this [ __ ] what sit in the front
row cuz yours you're the valedictorian
he's like oh my god I only [ __ ] his
son that was in a gang I can't believe
you joined the [ __ ] math club you
idiot that's what this is I guarantee it
I bet you $1,000 right now your math
club Betty all y'all thousand bucks each
so true thousand each what was it about
- well you said it cuz he was an early
it was it was just for the valley time
not even for know it so he was saying is
because his parents disowned they
actually are super super religious and
they made him go to conversion therapy I
heard conversion therapy though like
they like going there cuz it's a bunch
of other gay kids so they get to like
hook up and have like love times that
makes that's like Christian camp -
mm-hmm a lot of a lot of the gay kids in
Christian camp would hook up like crazy
can't wait
cuz everybody at Christian camp hooks up
yeah alright so Seth's parents gave him
an ultimatum either he would continue to
attend their church because he said that
he didn't want to go to that church
because they were just too against gays
so he asked can I go to a different
church and the parents said no either
you go to our church or you move out and
we don't suffer forced Christianity I
just love that no you need to [ __ ] go
to my church and feel the love of God
through my [ __ ] church all
right well that's that was a church that
he was doing the conversion therapy and
they were super like they would attack
him a lot because yeah of a sexual
orientation you're going to hell that's
what they're probably saying they end up
moving out
so he ended up moving out he's been
living with friends and he's been
working to sustain himself financially
but when he finally got an acceptance
letter from Georgetown University he was
super excited because like he that's the
school he wanted to go to but then when
he received his financial aid package
that's when he realized like you
wouldn't be able to attend the
university we can't afford it because
it's determined based on the expected
contribution of his family which his
family aren't supporting him can't you
emancipate yourself and be like check it
out y'all here's my story I'm the gay
and my parents they don't want to pay
well and it's the wrong kind of gay for
pay which is too bad oh yeah we want the
good kind yeah yes the Georgetown
refused to amend his financial aid
package and so he ended up needing to
get $20,000 for his first tuition first
year's tuition and so at that point you
just felt like you he was hopeless but
then his biology teacher stepped in who
was also gay and helped him set up a
GoFundMe and like as well as other
teachers they all stepped in and they
created this GoFundMe for stuff and as
of right now they raised one hundred and
twenty three thousand seven hundred and
thirteen dollars that's dumb it covers
all for you as easily yeah I will laugh
at my parents if I got that hahaha you
don't love me other people do there was
no greater conversion therapy for me
from religious to non-religious been
going to [ __ ] church dude that's true
holy [ __ ] it's just so the church pushes
me away from God keeps most of the
Catholic Church as I dude so much family
Catholic mmm-hmm there's no fun really
it's like a lot of repeated stuff and
rituals in its old school right yeah
like the new school like Protestant and
stuff they got the bands and stuff right
but they pick and choose it's like for
some reason Leviticus is a super loved
one where it's like you cannot lay with
another man but then like in Leviticus 2
is like don't eat shellfish but like I
see a lot of Christians are [ __ ] Red
Lobster dude I'm just saying and if you
mix fabrics you could get stoned or some
out
just [ __ ] like that or like if you work
on the Sabbath then you should die right
pretty crazy yeah well these parents are
Southern Baptists and they believe in
singing probably they believe in college
football take that oh yeah you're
supposed to be old school I think
Southern Baptists believe more on the
Old Testament side of things which is
more rules and in a New Testament side
of things is more like happy times to
different gods what's the same but the
personalities bipolar Old Testament God
is more mean and like rules rules and
like [ __ ] you're gonna die and [ __ ]
if you do the wrong thing New Testament
is like everybody cool everybody love I
love the idea Old Testament God being
like man I think I went too hard you
know what everybody's going back or for
a while sorry about that
yeah man sorry guys
do they unlike the new new test new New
Testament no well I without making it a
long hat story so technically the Old
Testament is the same Bible that Jewish
people believe in and then after that
the New Testament was compiled by the
Catholic Church which was I think it was
Constantine he was you know the Roman
Caesar or whatever he got all the
different people that were teaching
Christianity together and said all right
who's y'all gotta come up with one book
because you guys are getting too damn
popular and there's too many different
[ __ ] schools of thought like you got
the school of Paul you got the school so
it's or whatever now you need to get
together and have one book or else I'm
killing you fools and that's basically
what happened and then which one's like
the King James Version that's just old
English so they took like whatever Latin
it into English did he get metonymy he's
like I'll kill you if you don't write it
was four years yeah there was a time
limit that they just had to agree and so
there are some parts of the Bible that
didn't make it like there are other
things that were being passed around
it's a collection of books basically
so that's basically what happened story
time mother history but yeah it's really
it's a happy story happy ending so far
he looks happy you know what's
interesting is like the gay community is
considered a minority but it's something
that you discover it throughout life
whereas like ethnic minorities you just
born into it cuz like no one's like
sixteen and like you know what mom I
think I'm black unless you're that girl
that Vicki that she just realized she
was black halfway through life that's
happening nation and nobody sees peach
after remember that Rachel Dolezal
oh yeah that's her and she still says
she's black oh my god I love it
well what did she get arrested for a
welfare check fraud or something and
Indian people are saying that yep she's
black because she did some stupid like
that 5bb dope though what if in the
future that's people could pick and
choose because it will all be mixed so
people could pick and choose what they
want to identify culturally with so I
feel like a white guy you're super
stingy than your under agent part or
something yeah well what it'll probably
be is in the future will be so plugged
into the are [ __ ] that you really will
be able to pick and choose Oh cuz
everyone will be just stuck in their
glasses like I want to be black
yeah that's pretty tight clothing
optional it'll be a lot like that dude
you walk around nude and [ __ ] do
whatever you want [ __ ] jump into
traffic and stuff and then you come back
I know can't freaking wait so jump in in
traffic no just be like playing in the
warm having fun I would want to be
something so I could fight for rights
just just because we already talked
about you're talking about a game right
now yeah in a game that's so boring like
so like game is this the game is the get
it's called outrage alright just what
the game is called outrage and in so
like you know how in the future we're
thinking oh you you what we won't have
color lines and [ __ ] right but I will be
the person that's like okay today I'm
gonna vacation [ __ ] Asian activism or
something and then I get to I get to
complain about some [ __ ] and fight for
my rights
I thought you saying like it's like the
gay
is like civil rights in the 1960s or
whatever it's like flip it over it's
like you get to be Martin Luther King
and we play another game that's my [ __ ]
I'm gonna do that I mean you're kind of
doing that right now I know but it
doesn't feel the same so do you ever
watch historical [ __ ] and you feel like
that's a different thing a totally
different world than like what it is
today like if that's just a movie that's
true yeah that's how I feel I don't feel
like those people were real and they
live yeah like like kings and queens
there were human beings right they're
not [ __ ] fairy tales and [ __ ] like
that and kings and queens kind of exist
today in the corporate sense and like
celebrity right yeah we don't see it
like that a hundred years from now they
will say that [ __ ] about our Kim
Kardashian's and stuff which is weird
but that's what's gonna happen right so
I want to play the game like that I know
I can't believe like people like
Cleopatra I can't believe that that's
even real and like that [ __ ] she was
like real cuz you hear about it it's so
mythical and [ __ ] yeah she was probably
Kim Kardashian
she's my hardest [ __ ] right yeah she's
probably not though there's their photos
of her well their standards of beauty
back then was [ __ ] ugly dude do you
got like a normal as girl like I
probably looking at probably would be
the hottest woman on earth if I live
better you would be a hot piece of ass
the whole planet
[Music]